[Musica]
io sogno da piccolo era quello di stare
di fronte alle persone solo che ero un
po troppo timido per trovare il coraggio
per farlo ci ho messo più di trent'anni
è in realtà non c'è una volta che io non
abbia da persone di fronte che non mi
emozioni però adesso sono tante belle
persone sono sul mitico cerchio rosso
c'è un microfono con l'asta è
un'occasione unica e allora la voglio
cambiare programma non mi parla più di
ambiente ma di canto una canzone
di solito quando faccio questa cosa con
i più piccoli di chiedo di non ridere
loro però appena gli chiedo di non
ridere iniziano a rider nativamente
subito allora chiedo anche a voi mettete
la mano sul cuore promettete di non
ridere con un solo un cantante
professionista ecco mi manca anche la
giacchetta e quindi mi scuserete se
vorrei come dire sbagliare qualche nota
ci provo mi concentro un attimo pato
quando cominciano a vedere il mondo in
un modo diverso il mondo comincerà a
cambiare quando cominciare a vedere il
mondo in un modo diverso il mondo
comincerà a cantare quando comincerà a
vedere il mondo in un modo diverso il
mondo comincerà a cambiare rete
riconosciuta e marta sui tubi omar da
studi e il gruppo musicale e salvagente
del mitico gruppo marta sui tubi
peraltro questo passaggio e cantato dal
grande franco battiato ecco i marta sui
tubi ci imitano con il grande maestro a
guardare il mondo con occhi diversi
ci vuole uno strumento per guardare il
mondo con occhi diversi ci vuole un
cannocchiale rullo di tamburi delle
tette tenere questo cannocchiale io l'ho
portata con me
e allora prova a guardarvi con questo
cannocchiale un momento faccio tutto il
giro della platea
ma siete meravigliosi a vi ricordate
quando andavamo alle scuole medie ci
dicevano di guardare le stelle con un
rotolo di carta e giri perbacco
ho portato un rotolo di carta igienica
no in realtà io ho portato la anima del
rotolo di carta igienica e si qualche
settimane ma evidente questa frase dissi
tra me e me come dice qualcuno
in realtà la ditta che un po con un
rotolo di carta igienica quando finisce
rimane solo l'anima
ecco però torniamo un attimo ai bambini
che guardano verso il cielo
ma questo cinello è grande e dicevano to
monta quante stelle ci sono nelle coro
visivo e moltiplica per un certo numero
in realtà va fatto ma mi capitava sempre
quando era nuvoloso
ora avrete un buon abito io scherzo come
un bambino perché ho sempre a che fare
con i bambini perché il mio progetto
green o muori e poco merico
simpaticamente intanto no non lo rimetto
a posto perché mi serve di nuovo tra
poco vi devo fare una domanda chi segue
il progetto green o volo si rivolge ai
bambini dai 3 ai 90 tre anni e mi pare
che voi rientrati a pieno in questa
fascia d'età credo di più piccola in
sala sia mio figlio francesco che a
quasi dieci anni
c'è qualche 93 r non mi pare di no
quindi ci siamo allora a tutte queste
persone fa pongo questa domanda e
cooking kawasaki raccomando non chi ha
risposta secondo voi in your opinion e
base alle vostre conoscenze
quanto pesa un mito di carta igienica
nodo risposto e starete pensando questo
è un matto ha peraltro che cosa hanno
scritto chi nei sotto il vediamo un
attimo hanno già scritto nulla
io insegno all'università dopo questa
domanda vi starete chiedendo ma quando
mai non è possibile
ebbene vi invito a fare come cd con i
marta sui tubi venire le cose con occhi
diversi e con novello amleto non to be
or not to be as non essere di sodio cioè
il rotolo bello pieno i chiedono uso
non ditelo usano lo sa ma chiedo di
dirmi che cos'era questo rotolo quando
era piccolo si era un albero che poi è
stato tagliato con una motosega portato
sul cane entra di cartiere dipenda dalla
scatola di cartone un giornale un foglio
di carta
alla fine di questo meraviglioso ciclo
di vita avrà consumato siete seduti che
in piedi mi raccomando secco si reca da
qualche parte 8 mila litri d'acqua come
direbbe il professore per la vista umano
rubrica norio 8000 mila in acqua se
prendete questi 8.000 litri d'acqua e
prendete un rotolo da 500 strappi e fate
la proporzione diviene un momento cielo
per ogni strappo
eccolo qua ve ne facciamo l'esperimento
meno di calil è già amici ma una torre e
lo lasciamo cadere e leggerissimo no
anzi l'ho raccolto perché insegnano i
bambini che non si puntano le cose per
terra quindi lo prende un attimo se fate
la proporzione ritiene che questo
sottilissimo velo di carta equivale a 3
litri d'acqua 3 kg allora dobbiamo
guardare le cose con occhi diversi quali
quello dei bambini i bambini che quando
vado da loro e gli faccio per esempio
una cosa così no subito reagiscono
vediamo se poi reagite loro ricordato
per un gruppo musicale meraviglioso che
faceva we will rock you e allora fate le
vostre manine e raccomando non lo
vediate school cioè a facciamo parte del
genere umano
c'erano detto ai ragazzi del tenenze e
pare che abbiamo una solo gettone del
reno quindi mi raccomandano con gli
amici fuori manine e si fa così mi
raccomando
[Applauso]
ambiente ambiente tutto ciò che ci
circonda attenta a quel che fai
se come una fionda ogni nostra azione
produce qualche danno chi dice il
contrario
riprende con l'inganno ambiente ambiente
tutto ciò che ci circonda
attento a quel che fa sei come una
fionda a quel punto arriva sarebbe il
bambino quello che c'ha sempre mille
perché perché una fionda anziché
ridicono scusi ma cosa è una fionda e
già si capisce perché mai bambina si
contano le usano più noi da vincoli
bandinelli avremmo rotto con l'egitto va
bene forse non va bene
la fionda e quindi qual è il concetto
ecco io diffido purtroppo da chi
professa la teoria dell'impatto zero
l'impatto zero come è possibile che noi
facciamo qualcosa che non produca
alterazioni ogni cosa che fa l'uomo
produce dei danni chi dice il contrario
di prende con l'inganno e allora qual è
il segreto
ce l'hanno detto pure prima scegliere
dobbiamo fare la scelta più sostenibile
e che significa più sostenibile migliore
dal punto di vista ambientale economico
e sociale e potremmo sottotitolare era
amaro non è facile e molto difficile
però ci dobbiamo impegnare a guardare le
cose con occhi diversi e allora ecco
questo non è un rifiuto cioè qualcosa da
buttare da accettare come sta scritto su
quasi tutti i programmi di raccolta
differenziata come si punta come si
getta come diciamo noi in dialet ma
marietto cioè dare del buttare a gettare
un po progetto è una cosa brutta è
questo il motivo perchè mi sono
inventato il brutto rap dei rifiuti ora
inviterei di nuovo a battere le mani se
ve la sentite ormai siete già pastor
nativi dito ti vedono i banchi di scuola
aprono sedi sa come torneremo nei banchi
di scuola ma ci hanno dato delle
indicazioni precise chiarissime sappiamo
come fare
vabbè teniamo argomenti all'ordine va a
proposito del concetto di rifiuti
dobbiamo cambiare
come diceva vino daniele matan dall'area
santa cagna bocca andata non io in
grande mino ci avevo un video un
collegamento i bambini e il piemonte è
sembrata belle come uscire fuori dai
pregiudizi e allora io mi trovo a
coinvolgere col brutto rap dei rifiuti e
alla addirittura alla fine vi inviterò a
fare una cosa che fanno i bambini loro
sono bravissimi scoperti rebbero il
detto va bene
metaforicamente perché c'è stato mai c'è
un dice delle cose che le pronti ormai
aver imparato brano è sempre quello
quindi tutto ciao
tutto già tutto da buttare gettare li
voglio cancellare gli mettiamo già
pensare tempo di cambiare rifiuti
immondizia a come spazzatura che brutte
parole
a me fanno paura buttare accettare li
voglio cancellare e rimettiamoci a
pensare tempo di cambiare ridurre
riusare da qui voglio partire rispetto
per l'ambiente pochi soldi da gestire
buttare gettare vi voglio cancellare
rimediamo c a pensare il tempo di
cambiare
compra campa spreca dando pensa poco a
questo io non credo la vita non è un
gioco
sputare gettare mi voglio cancellare e
rimettiamoci a pesare tempo di equa
d'oca poi rifacciamolo mi raccomando un
bel cambiare forte tutto ciò tutto ciò
può dare
tentare e voglio accennare rimettiamoci
appezzare tempo di bravissimi siete
tornati dai cani fatevi un applauso
caloroso e tempo di cambiare a magari
acquistati change
corre voce che abbiamo un'unica
esperienza del rennes ha quindi mi
raccomando non vi diamo la bosina
io sono un ci tengo al rispetto delle
regole ma pure per questo bisogna essere
come dire un poco poi perché c'è
impegnativo rispettare le regole è una
cosa seria
quando è nata quest'idea dell'agri
smiling revolution di questi rap sindaci
che saltano sono dei rem sono delle
filastrocche e ritmate ho scoperto di
avere un talento per le rime cn vecchio
ne produce mondane e particolare prima
di chiudere con il primo re pedigree
napoli mi è venuto in mente un rap che
solitoni che qua non vi invito a battere
le mani perché questo per me è quasi
come una preghiera laica c'è voglia
proprio dai nas su rep
su affezionate e dice così vero rivelerò
mai ogni volte eco tra l'altro ringrazio
un'organizzazione che hanno fatto gol
spettacolari ci sta cena regale sappiamo
quando passi il tempo o team one ha
rubricato a ripetenti con il verbano
dice questa preghiera ma non della
voglio pero scritti in un momento che
era un ovvio dice l'arrivo a ritmo mar
ora mi concentro un altro tempo pazienza
passione e competenza pensa e ripensa
crea la conoscenza pensa agisci
controlla correggi impara dagli errori e
così in ghetti migliori tempo
ci vuole detto è mala e ciò va dalle vie
ed ha aspettato il flusso di cibo a
vicenza dice l'allievo al maestro
maestro qual è la cosa più importante o
maestro guarda e dice allievo mio
scivolava cheers senza pazienza non puoi
andare a larghe ma ci vuole anche la
passione ora se luci tempo pazienza e
passione ti costruisci le competenze con
le competenze crei la conoscenza si ma
il giorno paura di sbagliare e no e
becky è paura di sbagliare e perché
quando era piccola la maestra score di
punta sempre il dito
ricordati che devi sbagliare o che non
tiri sbagliati che tenga una cosmo
musica allora ciclo di training plan
duce cat che per i bambini diventa
messaggi si controlla corregge
addirittura comprino primi abbiamo fatto
una gallina la gallina poco controlla
correggi certi bambini questo che mi ha
insegnato mio nonno che aveva fatto la
seconda elementare il più grande maestro
che abbia mai incontrato una faccia
della terra sempre sempre sottana pianti
film una bottiglia di vino
ecco in questo secondo me era ispirato
che comunque diceva il nonno quando io
non l'ho ascoltato e commettiamo qualche
errore
lui mi diceva dopo che io naso mainero
fatto male ero caduto e mi diceva io
andavo lì cancello
cioè lui mi guardava settimana aspettavo
sornione che diceva così è o e trasuda
l'arte cioè adesso l'arte è entrata in
scena io non mi posso spostarmi perché
quelli manda dentro non ti devi muovere
sapevo che vi morirono i soldi quanti
scorribande quindi il nonno uno che
genera la seconda elementare aveva
capito come dire la scintilla della
cultura imparare dagli errori signor
errore nella montessori
ora vado a chiudere con il primo re
pedigree napoli è un giorno in una
scuola di pagani e scuola media i
bambini di club su visita al 6 simpatico
però il summit fi che sai mai che si può
fare è retto stato la berretti e come
funziona dovete fare le rime
cioè se litigo rima dune venire prima a
chi c'e dietro il tema l'acqua ai monti
o un difetto prendo tutto sul serio c'è
promuove per quano cmc modo impegnate
sono venuto rispettato gli orari
l'unica cosa ci parcheggiate non provi
precisi speriamo in europa
vabbè è dio celavano alto né di macchi
inizia pesa il tema era l'acqua bene era
un giorno aggiornato come dista faceva
cambini se pensavano a una voce acqua
acqua acqua arriva un semaforo ci state
resta aperta la signora di cgi nomadi le
serve una gran cotifosi io non vi
preoccupate un doppio arrivo a casa mia
moglie che verrà al prestito di fronte
mi vede dice pochi si sa che sempre
andata oggi perché si vedono la faccia
di quello che arriva con qualche cosa
minuto nel mio studio iniziò a scrivere
gli step presidente la mattina mi
sveglio ma mi dovrei muovono la proverò
a farlo
esco dallo studio di brin camera non ero
resa conto che hanno le 5 di mattina ma
ce l'ha o lo scritto si sentiva un
rumore di sottofondo che più o meno
faceva così
simeti corre voce che il gentil sesso
non si esibisca in questo sport
nazionale maschi ma la verità va al
nasir una manciata un po paesana anche
corre voce che le donne e la parità di
genere usciamo tutti quanti assieme
arriva il rousse avendo con le dico ciò
arrivano comunque le vecchie lire per
lei si mise a piangere ma le carte che
sensibile
oppure perché avrà pensato è una cosa
più probabile caro padreterno che sei
nei cieli
ma draghi quattro mesi quante miliardi
siamo 73 miliardi 2 ormai van gogh
stucchi camere avvicinati ma io per
vedere se pure voi piangente o evidente
secondo me viasat e teniate pancia
l'assenza forza il brutto notte se lo
sciocco sciacquare beach che ne nota si
chiamava il piccolo re della pop rock
con grande successo successo ma fanno un
piccolo
vabbè fuori da successi futuri nevi di
ritmo e se fosse insieme lo faccio
sentire con questo ci amiamo ma come
sono e quindi idealmente mo di saluto
pure quindi verrebbe poi una replica
l'abbiamo messa in apposito quindi è
inutile che vado allora il ritmo è
quello vela accompagnamento tutto ciao
ciao
ciao sciacqua sciacqua stai attento
all'acqua sciacqua s'acqua sciacqua ma
usa poca acqua l'acqua è poca
la papera non galleggia l'acqua sembra
tanta ma invece a pescarsi giacona
sciacqua sciacqua ma stai attento
all'acqua sciacqua sciacqua sciacqua
pausa poca acqua penser rimessa quando
hanno il rubinetto una spegnere il
cervello quando mai al gabinetto
sciacqua s'acqua ma stai attento
all'acqua sciacqua sciacqua sciacqua la
musa poca acqua goccia dopo goccia tu
vuoi svuotare il mare
proprio per questo il gesto può contare
allora sciacqua sciacqua ma stai attento
all'acqua sacco sacco sciacqua pausa
poca acqua oro argento pini che diamanti
se l'acqua nel deserto sono solo cambi
in acqua sciacqua stai attento all'acqua
sacco sacco sharp a usa poco
con questo d'agri novoli che tutto vi
ringrazio per avermi ascoltato con santa
pazienza e vi do appuntamento sia il
canale youtube tigri napoli mi
raccomando andate lì e cliccate
discrimine iscriviti script iscriviti
questo è che io sono grato gli amici di
edy perché ci stanno dando la
possibilità di condividere le idee e
quindi la mia idea si chiama gri popoli
grazie e voce
[Applauso]
[Musica]